how does one get good at programming to
say that you're good at it means then
you have come pretty close to a mastery
on some aspect of it it doesn't really
matter what language it doesn't really
matter if it's math or technical ability
or a combination of both
you are good at anything in the realm
you can probably say that you are a good
programmer get away with it
the real question is what are you trying
to do what is your goal
that's the question you should be asking
that is the question that will get to
the root
what you need to do
- just say you want to
learn to be a programmer was too generic
you need
some examples of our goals would be a
design of an application that does
something
in particular
and you must decide what you wanted to
run on
that'll affect what you do
if you want to make an Android app want
to make something that runs on Android
phones you're probably going to need to
learn Java or Kotlin or you're going to
need to understand how the API works so
you can design your app and then hire a
programmer in which case you don't
really need to know much about program
so it depends what angle your
perspective you're looking at this
if you're a developer and you want to
code up everything yourself need to
think about the underlying technologies
if you are an investor or an inventor
you're just an ideas guy someone that
could throw some money at something to
make it grow in the future
have a good outlet look
or maybe you're a business owner that's
a whole different thing and you don't
necessarily need to code it's more about
your communication skills
of course and understanding of what it
takes is huge so you will have to do
some research but you won't have to dive
in really deep and understand every
little thing about Java this can the
same can be said for Windows apps games
things for any OS
most of you watching this channel will
probably probably be interested in Cody
I imagine that's what I'm interested in
but recent events have made me shift my
perspective
so I am starting to highly consider the
fact that I can't
I put too much on my plate
and there's only a limited amount of
time
the time it takes for me to complete an
app to the level that I happy with it
it's too large
but if I had a team
and the proper setup so it depends what
angle you're looking at making this
project from what you should be focusing
on
want to be the person that's part of
your team that can deliver on their end
so you need to be looking into the
technologies and the know-how from what
you are delivering
so that's really it and as things change
we have to keep an open mind that's
really important you get stuck in the
same way stuck in the same program stuck
in the same editor stuck in the same
language
you're gonna hit roadblocks that you
can't overcome you have to be willing to
take that take a step back take a few
days and learn something new
that better fits
the technology or working on
so it's not an easy question to answer
there's a lot of analysis that goes into
a question like that in most of it
it's things you need to ask yourself or
if it's not up to you you need to be
asking your boss or your team or at
least you need to be asking the internet
and working upon presenting some
material to your team
or your boss that you think would be a
good path and then you can hash that out
with them
and figure it out
it's important to be honest in these
sort of setups
it's very unethical to be dishonest what
happens is when you talk your stick up
your skills over what they are or you
say you can deliver something you can't
is your wasting
not just your own time but everybody
else's time and the worst part about
this isn't even that although that's
quite bad
everybody that you do this to lose a
little bit of respect for you
every time you say you can deliver
something and you can't but they'll only
lose that respect if you to the bitter
end
don't ask for help and don't ask for
direction but don't say right away that
hey I think I see a better way or don't
ask you know if if you close off and say
you can do it and then you don't that's
when it's a problem that's what I'm
trying to say here if you're very open
about the fact that look this isn't
going as well as I thought I'm not sure
I know how to do this exactly I could
use some help or
or maybe someone else should do this and
I should do something else if you're
straightforward like that
we'll follow you we just have to say
something saying nothing
okay siren
cybron in a world where social media is
so big everybody's posting their things
every day it sure seems like everybody's
really quite closed off I mean there are
some groups where it's not like this but
I personally feel this way when I log on
to Facebook and see my 300 or so friends
I feel very closed off sure I could say
stuff that puts me in the in the place
where I am
that's
tricky because
usually you only want to say this to a
few people and you have a lot of people
a lot of Randi you're generally speaking
to the open a public and you're posting
your status
if they're even listening but the thing
is they can listen
and you're revealing something about
yourself so usually you want to keep
that private between just your team and
you're working with
your social media needs to be
unfortunately sort of in this case at
least needs to be more of an outside
perspective of you of all your best
points all your strong points because if
you make it something else well you know
I gotta turn the wipers
now I have no clue nor judgment I don't
particularly care but most people are
very okay with wasting time you know I
can see this and myself too
so
I get it but that's not an okay way to
be that's very on an ethical way of
behaving
you're wasting people's times I care
about
so if you want to keep good+ company and
I suppose you just got
maintain that communication with the
value
the ones that are bringing you down
hard thing to do but that's what it
takes to become a better person that's
what it takes to become a better leader
so it takes to become a better coat or
what it takes to to get a better life
I just have to set the standards
forced it into your best
to live up to your own standards and
that's what I need to do that's what I
want to do going forward I'm gonna try
my best
it's going to be a party welcome to my
journey
you